to kick it off we have a wonderful guest
on zoom she's the founder and ceo
of oma beauty and the bold leader of
make it black and pull up for
change which are two initiatives in
beauty that changed the game
she is friend of the show sharon shooter
happy beauty week
hi hi sharon
all right well we're going to start the
news with what people are freaking out
about
it's a hot new filter on instagram and
it's called
pillow face um and yahoo life reports
that it transforms your face to show you
what you would look like if you went
straight to filler town and
went a little banana all right so
take a look at these pics um actress
ashley benson posted one sophie
turner went to this and
lily collins also joined in on the fun
and the filter was started for fun but
it's become a very strong visual way
of you know talking about extremes
injectables
plastic surgery uh ross and i took it
for a spin
yeah i'm opposed to this um but i
secretly kind of want to look like this
and this is what i'd look like if i
got if i really went crazy town and
oh i have to say god i know it was sort
of a joke and then i looked at him like
well i hate percent of it but
ross i would tackle you although it's a
funny app it does sort of say something
of what people are doing
i did it you did it my picture
oh drew by the way i look like my mother
and jocelyn wildenstein i love child
it's literally it's my mom and the cat
lady had a baby
this is this is so not okay oh my god i
want you to show up like that sharon
what do you think because you know i
love your opinion
on well pretty much everything yeah yeah
i mean look i'm like everybody to their
own thing right beauty is in the eyes of
the beholder
but um look i fortunate enough that i've
always had giant lips so i don't relate
to the problem so so sometimes i'm like
i can sit this one out
it's true you've got like the lips the
bone structure
you you've got what everybody's trying
to get um
lucky now i used to get bullied for it i
used to get called a frog
because back then it wasn't trendy so i
was just this person walking around with
all of this and all of that
and so now i'm i'm having shopping for
it i'm actually now just
sitting there laughing going like yay
now it's trendy
that's amazing that you're so lucky
right when you're insecure
oven yourself becomes the trend you know
one day i have double chins is like the
whole thing
yeah everyone's kidding injections down
here
sharon i think you've been on trend then
now and forever and sharon you have also
got the next story
oh i'm telling you so so this one i'm
once again the bearer of bad news so
confident post just reported that
whatever makeup you've bought
free pandemic you got to chuck it you
have to throw it out
so now i'm going to tell you that i'm
verifying that that's
actually true so let me tell you
something drew to most of you don't know
on your makeup product there is always a
label that looks like a container
there's half open
with a number on it it is called period
after opening
for mostly products is between eight to
twelve months for most
eye products is about six months so a
lot of consumers don't pay attention to
that tiny little detail
but for your own you know sanity for
your own hygiene
you've got to pay attention to that and
you got to track it so
people don't know this but please go
into your makeup cabinet and almost
everything pre-pandemic is gonna be
ready to be thrown out so
you've got to chop them out after a
while so just giving you that squeeze
it's true you cannot buy in bulk
and you have to refresh when it comes to
makeup i'm really glad you brought this
into light because i think a lot of
people
don't want to waste their money and then
they're not necessarily being hygienic
and it's safer
to start fresh sharon this story really
spoke to me because um you were just
highlighted in a vogue
business piece about the fashion
industry
can learn from the all-purposeful
activism in the beauty industry and
you are one of my favorite leaders in
this you know you're changing the beauty
industry with pull up for change
and make it black do you think that the
fashion
industry can step up in certain ways
are you interested in calling them out
they're watching what you're doing
what can they do well i think they
really need to understand the role that
they play you know
and it's really been for me really
disheartening seeing how
the industry has sort of tried to sit
this out and it's because it's a real
exclusive industry
it's an industry that is not used to
listening to its consumers
and for now it's an inconvenience
because they know you still got to buy
clothes right you're not
how you're going to boycott that right
so so i
am very hopeful that we'll see more
action because right now
fashion as an industry hasn't moved in
the way beauty which is a very
democratic industry an
industry that right now is 100
controlled by the
consumer um has actually moved to the
place so i want to see
some fashion brands really leading the
charge and making meaningful change not
only in diversity but in sustainability
too
when you like you know really
tell people what they need to do and
when they need to do it
they do leap into action you have such
strength
intelligence and conviction i look
forward to seeing your
challenging of this industry ross that
was so well said i never thought about
it like that the differences between the
beauty industry and the fashion news
consumer driven exactly and also in
addition to that you recently launched
a collaboration with coming to america
that's all about celebrating
black beauty can you tell us about that
look how gorgeous that
is right now i'm still
in that moment um you know for me coming
to america was a huge part of my
childhood this was the first time
for me not only being black but being
african we saw ourselves on the big
screen you know looking elevated and not
you know
it wasn't a live aid another poverty
kind of brigade and so we went in
on this collection i was under pressure
to represent
my entire continent properly and so for
me
i quite literally snapped this is the
most
personal collection i've ever made but
in terms of the texture the formulas
and just to look at that look at that
like
come here to play so and through this i
highlight stories of my culture
and through this collection i'm taking
all of my consumers
to the real african royalty and real
royal heritage so i'm really excited
about this one you should be this is
beautiful
so good yeah it's the color energy of
the film
right here in a palette beautiful job
yes um
thank you before we go it's beauty week
on the show and i was wondering if you
could share
one beauty tool tip hack
anything you're obsessed with right now
that we need to know about oh my god
okay
i have a lot but i'm going to keep it
short for you guys we're still in the
zoom world i know we're still trying to
come out here
but i'm going to tell everybody just
having the mascara on the top and bottom
lid
everybody forgets the bottom put it on
the
bottom and you will get a full your eyes
will just instantly
well sharon we will be putting it on the
bottom on the top
and you are just our hero we love you
thank you so much for joining us
again today for the umpteenth time and
let's do many more